un motard de la gendarmerie et en du
gène constitue cette escorte
impressionnante dans les rues de
fort-de-france matin juste pour un
détenu placé sous haute surveillance
depuis le centre pénitentiaire de ducos
le faut y aller
cédric chaillot 35 ans assisté de son
avocat maître luc cayol est reconduit à
sa demande devant un juge d'instruction
du tribunal de grande instance
si lors de sa garde à vue il avait juste
fourni quelques éléments d'information
constructeur il avait exercé son droit
de réserve
chaillot est mis en examen pour avoir
volontairement donné la mort à daniel du
ville
cela non tilloy de 23 ans non loin du
maximus le 26 juillet dernier et est
aussi poursuivi pour violences avec arme
sur notre jeune homme devant cette
discothèque du lamentin autres charges
retenues à son encontre
il est mis en examen pour détention
illégale d'une ou de plusieurs armes à
feu et de munitions
tous ces faits ont été commis en
récidive légale par rapport à des
condamnations antérieures de la cour
d'assises dès mineurs mais aussi du
tribunal correctionnel de fort-de-france
à la suite de mouvements d'un syndicat
pénitentiaire
chaillot a été depuis placés à
l'isolément les motifs de sa demande
d'audition font partie de l'instruction
de ce dossier
ils ne peuvent être communiquées son
avocat maître le cayol nos précise que
pour le moment son client père de
famille de trois enfants bénéficient de
la présomption d'innocence
et comme toute personne impliquée dans
une action justice chaillot a droit à
l'assistance d'un avocat